with the first Qashqai in 2007 his son
essentially created the crossover
segment the aim was clear to develop an
SUV that had all the advantages of a
normal passenger car the koshkas natural
environment was curvy country lanes not
off-road terrain and that was reflected
in the way it drove
he says so today Kurtis to Sasha can op
says that you only need to drive a few
meters to realize that this is a car
with a good chassis the bumps in this
road are smoothed out and the steering
is good when all see link on this for my
English monk all scientists Ilocano the
design of the next generation of
Qashqai's has been made sharper the
front end is dominated by the arrow
shaped headlights with daytime running
lights the unpainted under ride
protection and over arches reveal the
vehicles off-road pedigree the sloping
lines of the roof however say passenger
car the rear end with the spoilers is
also more sporty than robust
is there enough room for passengers in
the back Sasha says yes he has room for
his knees and his head although his hair
does brush the roof but that doesn't
bother him Sasha also likes the view
through the sunroof the vaccine is the
best place to enjoy that the view to the
rear is restricted by the cars design on
the other hand the Sun offers the
surround view system which gives you a
bird's-eye view of the vehicles that's
particularly helpful for parking on a
full width perspectiva from Ultron gets
like and glad about mind parking SS
you've also faced the system is a
standard feature of the deluxe version
unfortunately the interior looks cheaper
than it actually is still this model
does have partial leather seats and a
leather covered gear stick
sasha says that if you've got your key
in your pocket you can unlock the trunk
like this the trunk has a volume of 430
liters which can be expanded to 1585
liters by putting the seats down the
rear seating is divided into where as a
triple division would have been better
that makes the car less versatile than
it could be the car we tested is
equipped with a 1.6 liter diesel engine
all-wheel drive and an automatic
transmission our options we're happy
with the front-wheel drive the car has a
capacity of 96 kilowatts and a top speed
of 183 kilometers an hour the automatic
transmission makes the motor a bit
sluggish it takes 11.1 seconds to go
from zero to a hundred this son
developed the technology in conjunction
with Renault
listen Sasha says with the new cash
kindness Sun has improved on something
that was already good with its fuel
efficiency and good basic features it's
a serious alternative for small families
the standard version of the car cost
just under twenty thousand euros in
Germany
meaning it's an affordable vehicle that
combines safety with drivability like
earlier models than this on Qashqai has
the potential to be a real hit
you